oh ja okay ich mache viele leute meinen
zu mir hey luca du hast jetzt ein
paarmal auf hilfen reagiert er reagiert
auch bitte mal auf krass schule die
jungen lehrer mache ich heute
wir schauen uns allerdings erst mal an
was das ganze überhaupt ist die serie
dreht sich um fünf jungen lehrer die ihr
referendariat an der fiktiven erich
velbert gesamtschule in köln
warum wird diese attacke immer in köln
gedreht ich bin ganz ehrlich wir
brauchen uns diese handlung gar nicht
mehr weiter durch lesen ich glaube
nämlich dass man sich schon denken kann
worum es hier geht
es ist eine rtl 2 serie hat irgendwas
mit schule und besonderen fällen zu tun
hier sehen wir beispielsweise illegales
autorennen oder die verhüllte schülerin
und dann so ein thumbnail das sind aziz
auf einer fiktiven schule die sozial
sage ich mal ein bisschen am arsch sind
ich habe jetzt einfach mal irgendeine
dieser krass schule folgen rausgesucht
und zwar die folge mit dem titel die
neue sexbombe wir schauen uns erst mal
an was darunter so viel kommentare
geschrieben wurden das ist doch keine
sexbombe sexbombe kann man das nicht
nennen wenn das eine sexbombe ist mag
ich donald trump ihre zähne haben
dieselbe farbe wie ihre haare ich finde
die halt gar nicht hübsch als die
braunhaarige tausend mal geil diese
scheinen sieht aus wie mein fuß java
sexbombe wer sich auf die einen runter
holt bekommt von mir richtige bombe
ja wir sehen schon was das auch für
kommentarschreiber da sind allerdings
würde ich sagen langsam langsam
ich würde sagen wir schauen jetzt
allerdings auf waren die folge rein
bevor wir das ganze allerdings tun
möchte ich euch noch ganz kurz eben
sagen das heute gerade eben neue
klamotten online gekommen sind in denen
es gibt seit einigen stunden fünf neue
produkte im luca - shop.de und zu den
ersten 2000 bestellungen bekommt ihr
auch eine signierte autogrammkarte also
schaut dort gern mal vorbei aber jetzt
fangen wir erstmal an mit der wii action
also das hier ist das kind rom und es
geht jetzt hier los in der schule und
das die sexbombe okay okay die schauen
die sich schon an bin ich ja mal
gespannt jeder guckt hin die nehmen
sogar cup
[Musik]
also soll jetzt nicht beleidigen klingen
aber in meinen augen ist das auf keinen
fall eine sexbombe als wenn jemand sagt
hey das ist eine sexbombe dann denke ich
mir okay das muss ja der perfekteste
mensch sein den es gibt natürlich ist
das eine subjektive einschätzung die
jeder individuell für sich selbst
beurteilen muss welchen mensch er sage
ich mal perfekt schön findet aber das
ist das war so als wird dann einmal auf
den kopf gesetzt werden und einfach so
lange daran schneiden überhaupt nicht
gegen die schauspielerinnen gehen oder
so auf gar keinen fall aber das als
sexbombe zu betiteln finde ich ein
bisschen falsch alle gucken sich immer
noch um ok
sie sieht vor allem
halt aus als wird sie nicht mehr zur
schule gehen ich möchte euch ich finde
noch sehr stark das war so ein handtuch
über dem skelett hängt also die steuern
ist anscheinend neu an dieser friede
kelbert köln porz gesamtschule ganz ganz
schwieriger name bald schauen wie die
cheyenne ihren ersten tag geht's hier
bestreiten wird
da wir direkt platz gemacht mal ganz
kurz wie wenig leute sind denn in dieser
klasse also ich weiß nicht wie es an
gesamtschulen ist oder wieder die
klassengröße aussieht sage ich mal aber
hier sind halt insgesamt 13 leute oder
12 ich weiß nicht wie waren 30 leute bei
uns in der klasse der ist der lehrer ok
dann setzt neben maria was fünf
aussteller alles normal aus
dass diese ganzen rtl2 serien so darauf
abzielen ja wir haben hier aziz und dann
kommen neuerdings dazu und dann
versuchen sie ist die neue sie ist
irgendwie in ihre kölner babos oder was
war das letztes mal zu uns
dass köln war es das war aber dieser
hilft mir folge da irgendwie der fall
auf die ich vor ein paar tagen reagiert
habe ja es zielt irgendwie immer darauf
ab dass man irgendwie andere leute für
sich ausnutzt menschenrechte sind
ziemlich abstoßend also das hier ist
jetzt die schule anscheinend er macht
einen krassen skateboard trick die haben
jetzt unterricht ende
und ja sie sieht nicht schlecht aus aber
sie jetzt für den titel zu missbrauchen
als die neue sexbombe find ich ja okay
es ist rtl2 wir schauen mal weiter das
nämlich freundin möglich dass gesichter
zu freunden
diese räumliche mega ausstrahlung hat
sie ja also eine mega ausstrahlung
die beiden gehen jetzt rüber zu der show
also ich frage mich wirklich
mehr warum der top kommen 10.000 likes
hatte
naja mal schauen
die mädchen am anti fdp zu verlieren
perfekte antwort was haben aber direkt
schon auffällt ist dass das ganze
irgendwie tatsächlich besser gespielt
ist vor allem die szene bei der wir hier
gerade wahllokale draußen standen ist
viel besser gespielt als hilf mir also
krass schule ist nicht so krass a si
also ich finde im übrigen marvin heimat
hast du überhaupt nicht jetzt irgendwie
dazwischen gerede traurigen kommt rüber
zu den anderen
der mann stellt sich vor ich bin happy
end
das würde
typische kag smalltalk hey wie gehts dir
was hast du für hobbys hast du dich
schon eingelebt die es in halben tag
grad an der schule wie soll sie sich
daran bisher gut eingelebt haben einfach
mal rum pfeifen während die da erzählt
dass sie sport macht
ja und ihr seid die coolen hier ja wenn
du so ein bisschen an uns selbst dann
geht's nicht glaube ich ganz gut gehen
jetzt hier glaube ich ganz gut gehen
wenn sie sich an die hält
es ist ja schon kretzschmar ist es ein
paar aber auf der letzten klassenfahrt
liefert zwischen uns und jetzt am ersten
schultag
also ganz ehrlich ich finde sie
tatsächlich hübscher als diese seien
sexbombe aus hamburg aber wie ich ja
immer bei solchen rtl2 reaktionen et
cetera sage ist es nichts gegen die
leute irgendwie persönlich oder so dass
es einfach nur meine individuelle
anschauung auf die dinge also ich möchte
niemanden verletzten hätten oder sonst
irgendwas sondern ich reagiere auf die
schauspieler und nicht auf die personen
dahinter
denn so einfach
b
und warum hat der haus
rolex
rolex die neue mich nicht gerade krass
an gemacht hat und fristig im wesen das
hast du ja sehr gut erkannt ich stehe
auf mich ich glaube ich werde gleich mal
anbieten hier die schule zu zeugen alter
da wird sich ja jedes mädel freunden
beisammen
ich weiß nicht wir könnten was essen
gehen oder ins kino oder schwimmen gehen
oder einfach so chillen nee ich würde
dir ganz gern mal unsere schule zeigen
dass hier
ich finde es dass diese hier einfach mal
so rum rollt also der marvin zeigt jetzt
der cayenne hier so ein bisschen die
schule herum und jetzt kommen die
freunde von dem namen an und der mann
erzählt so ein bisschen darüber ja wir
haben hier partys veranstaltet blabla
die hier vorne sind bisschen
eifersüchtig und jetzt kommt der sport
in der freizeit
jetzt verstehe ich was da abgeht cayenne
wird anscheinend nicht beef mit der
maria haben sondern der marvin mit dem
lukas weil der mann eigentlich die
verlängert aber der lukas will die
schalen und jetzt will der lukas die
cayenne von dem marvin wegnehmen durch
ein sportangebot obwohl die ja mal in
der cayenne gerade noch die schwimmer
also marvin mit mathe da helfen
ok jetzt soll der look deutsch helfen
okay das heißt die medien die alle da
weg zu trainiert hat er die chance und
er wird auch weggenommen
das ist ja
der schwachsinn was da abläuft
tobias nicht redet ihr auch noch mit
maria und mich dadurch noch macht wohl
dank für den tipp
kein problem also falls das nötig da die
maria und cayenne kommen gut miteinander
aus und die anderen die sind gerade
gegeneinander also ein bisschen in ihrer
clique hier ist ja was los die lästern
alle und führen sich voll cool wenn ich
hier überleben möchte dann werde ich auf
jeden fall zeigen dass das spiel auch
spielen kann
trust aber wieder gut dass die folge
jetzt einfach vorbei ist und man
eigentlich nichts mitbekommen hat das
einzige was wir bisher wissen ist dass
er die studentin aus hamburg nach köln
gezogen ist jetzt neu an der schule ist
und jeder der jungs prügelt sich sage
ich mal so ein bisschen um die cheyenne
und die anderen mädels die was von den
jungs wollten sind jetzt so
untergeordnet mal schauen wie es
weitergeht wenn ihr nämlich wollt dass
sich auf den zweiten teil dieser folge
reagiere oder ich weiß gar nicht gibt es
einen zweiten teil oder sind das alles
weiter die teile ich habe überhaupt
keinen plan von dieser serie freunde
wenn jeder genaueres wissen und ob es
vielleicht auch im zweiten teil gibt auf
denen ich reagieren kann schreibt mir
gerne und in die kommentare soll ich
überhaupt noch mal darauf reagieren
zeigt mit dem daumen hoch und bei 50.000
likes ja das zeigt mir auf jeden fall
dass er da bock drauf habt
[Musik]
ein